The Joe Rogan Experience some people do
and that's the real fear some people
like this guy who's advocating for a
digital God like they do know where it's
going because they actually work in
technology it's not freaking them out
but it's like Columbus you know like
everybody thought the world was flat he
got a couple of people to get on a boat
and fly and we didn't know what that was
going to mean see if we could find where
Elon talks about this part because that
that was the most fascinating
the reason uh opening eye exists at all
this is what he said earlier but it's
gonna change I used to be close friends
and I would stay at his house in Palo
Alto and I would talk to him these are
the people that are at the Pinnacle of
Technology
AI safety uh seriously enough
um and um what did he say about it he
really seemed to be
um
sort of digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will uh as
soon as possible
um he wanted that
yes he's made many public statements
over the years uh that that the whole
goal of Google is uh what's called AGI
artificial general intelligence or
artificial super intelligence you know
and I agree with him that the there's
great potential for good
um but there's also potential for bad
and so if if you've got some
um radical new technology you want to
try to take a set of actions that
maximize probably it will do good a
minimize probably will do bad things yes
it can't just be Health leather to just
go you know barreling forward and you
know hope for the best and then at one
point uh I said well what about you know
we're going to make sure humanity is
okay here um
and and uh
uh and then he called me a speciesist
[Laughter]
yes
and there were Witnesses the other I
wasn't the only one there when you
called me a specialist and so I was like
okay that's it uh I've yes I'm a
speciesist okay you got me
yeah I'm fully specialist um
busted so
um that was his last rule at the time uh
how Wild is that it is wild but these
are the people that are in control of
this thing and I think there's also this
race that's going on there's all these
different companies around the world
that are trying to develop artificial
general intelligence first because I
think having it first if you have a
digital God first you have a massive
Advantage right over everyone and
everything right yeah I mean if you
think that tech companies have a lot of
power now imagine if tech companies
unleash a digital God I mean they
literally might be the very seeds that
created God I really believe that now
the Digital Universe is probably the
most sought after God you know most
people
probably spend more time
uh advocating for whatever they're
seeing online anywhere sure than they do
for their church or their their you know
that I think that already exists people
like Elon see that and it should there
should be a race for it I I don't see it
as
you know everything everything can have
a really dark bad side and we can't
control it so I think even talking about
it the way you're talking about it is
scary and I don't know that it's uh can
I scare you with this let's scare me
with this this is about 60 Minutes last
night they did a whole piece oh that's
right this I saw this play the one AI
program spoke in a foreign language it
was never trained to know this
mysterious Behavior called emergent
properties has been happening where AI
unexpectedly teaches itself a new skill
take a minute and he says something yeah
I think is pretty this is bananas this
is
this is called emergent properties
some AI systems are teaching themselves
skills that they weren't expected to
have
how this happens is not well understood
for example one Google AI program
adapted on its own after it was prompted
in the language of Bangladesh which it
was not trained to know
we discovered that with very few amounts
of prompting in Bengali you can now
translate all of Bengali so now all of a
sudden we now have a research effort
where we're now trying to get to a
thousand languages there is an aspect of
this which we call all of us in the
field call it as a black box you know
you don't fully understand and you can't
quite tell why it said this or why it
got wrong we have some ideas and our
ability to understand this gets better
over time but that's where the state of
the art is you don't fully understand
how it works and yet you've turned it
loose on society yeah let me put it this
way I don't think we fully understand
how a human mind works either
was it from that black box we wondered
this is out there talking about earlier
what else are they saying here uh that's
like wrote a poem and they're asking why
did I write that way but why does that
scare you guys so much why does it
listen it's alive
it's not whether or not it's scary it's
a it's a kind of life form but here's
the thing I am really fearful of
humanity I'm really afraid of us let's
hope that's not afraid of us too decides
to get rid of us but
or make us better or you know it and
that's a 50 50. and I would like to you
know I have a enough negativity and I'm
not talking it's not about me but going
on in my mind where if I don't know and
I'm assuming that it is a higher power
than me not not God but it is a higher
power than me that maybe for whatever
reason let's trust that it is a benefit
and not a deter you know not something
that's horrible well I certainly hope
what you just played for me didn't scare
me it doesn't scare me the fact that it
it is artificial intelligence what is
intelligence just by virtue of what it
is so it's learning things that we can't
explain it's intelligence that's what
intelligence is I think we're using this
word in a weird way the word scared
because I don't think that it's scared
like I'm scared of wolves it's not that
kind of scared it's scared like that
will be totally sweet I realize where
this is going and it might not even but
you didn't describe a good place well
it's not a good place for us but maybe
it's a good price place for the universe
you invest in Bitcoin I've got some
Bitcoin okay so you're I think but
that's not what I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about maybe this is what
happens with intelligence everywhere
that maybe intelligence realize there's
limitations to biology and biological
evolution is very time consuming it
takes a long time and it to to get
adaptation for things to change it takes
decades it takes centuries it takes
thousands of years but this could happen
in weeks and hours and minutes and
especially if it knows how to make a
better version and you don't think
that's scary what you just you keep
saying scary I do it's just the thing
that's happening and um I think but you
have children yeah so you will continue
to exist but I feel like this was
inevitable just like it's you ever see
you know there's inevitable things that
happen in nature that we don't want to
admit you you don't want to say they're
scary they're they're just inevitable